nicolas vidal directeur de publication
de putsch médias bonsoir nicolas vidal
merci d'être avec nous sur rt france un
commentaire sur ces huit minutes
est-ce que l'allocution du premier
ministre a été à la hauteur de la
gravité de la situation selon vous pour
moi c'est pas un conseil de défense un
conseil de la désespérance est
absolument affligeant jean castex est
venu on a reporté à 16 heures et à 16
heures puis 7 et à 17h puis finalement
il est passé a dit à 17h40 ça fait
penser un peu finalement au découpage
des régions de françois hollande avec
jean marc ayrault lorsqu'il a fallu
finir sur un bout de papier
et là c'est pareil on a repoussé on a
repoussé tout le monde était assez
attendait un ses déclarations je les ai
vu moi même dans mon entourage ou à
droite à gauche qu'est ce qui va nous
annoncer on parle de gros confinement
peut-elle localiser partiel et
finalement pour moi très sincèrement ça
a été d'une indigence et pas eu grand
chose et que l'aide de camp d'emmanuel
maquereau en la personne de jean castex
est devenu une espèce de cochon chanter
un code chanter pour pour la france et
c'est assez c'est assez effrayant voilà
je le dis j'ai été très déçu par là
c'était très court et finalement il y
avait pas grand chose dans ce discours
traitement qu'est ce qu'il aurait fallu
en attendre des médecins disent déjà par
rapport à ce qui se passe à marseille
notamment ouverture de l'e recrutement
de personnel en prévision justement de
doni sous tension des lits à l'hôpital
c'est le cas effectivement bon on a
entendu
soyons en soyons tout à fait objective
du moins deux mille 2000 recrutement
donc bien s'est-il temps de faire des
recrutements mais l'hôpital je crois
énormément besoin aussi de renfort très
beau très prochainement et d'ailleurs
pour le fonctionnement habituel de
l'hôpital on aurait pu alors après je
voulais revenir aussi on a toujours la
criminalisation des français en les
français ont pas fait ça les français
ont pas fait si fede france il en était
quand même bien gentil concrètement
pendant huit mois de mettre en place les
gestes barrière d'essayer de se confiner
parce que c'était calme une épreuve
nationale le confinement et on continue
à nous dire les français le notre avenir
sanitaire passera par vous je crois que
les français ont fait leur part du
boulot me semble-t-il
et il y avait toute une série alors si
la situation est grave il fallait
prendre des mesures beaucoup plus
drastiques on a toujours l'impression je
reviens toujours à ce problème de
planning dans l'horaire on a toujours
impression finalement quand on navigue à
vue et c'est assez c'est assez étonnant
et j'étais vraiment très sincèrement
très déçu je parlerai notamment des
entreprises il a rien été dit les
entreprises aujourd'hui vous avez des
grands groupes des petits pmu qui
attendait justement les déclarations de
jean castex pour savoir comment
fonctionner dès lundi parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le flou le plus
absolu entreprise est il finalement il
n'y a pas eu grand chose donc on nous a
parlé de la n'y avait pas de baisse vie
de bez arre charge virale à paraître qui
avait pas de ligne maginot
mais tout ça ce sont des mots
concrètement une nouvelle fois on
continue à dire aux français qu'ils font
finalement que ça repose sur eux locaux
vides et qu'il va falloir qu'il se remet
en vraiment je pense qu'ils se sont bien
remonté les manches pendant huit mois et
je suis très sincèrement je suis très
très déçu de ce discours parce qu'on
nous en attendant tous aussi c'est très
difficile aujourd'hui d'avoir des
informations d'avoir une vision claire
sur ce qui se passe en france et je
trouve très sincèrement que pour ce
disque au premier ministre et à c est
assez frais en rappel au séisme vous
l'avez dit de la part du premier
ministre il il en appelle également
finalement aux élus locaux ce seront aux
élus locaux finalement d'adapter les
mesures en fonction de la situation
locale
ils renvoient la balle bah oui il le
fait tout le fond tout le temps c'était
pas lui au début de la crise c'était
leur fibre mais rappelez-vous sur les
mers rappelez-vous sur les premiers
temps aux élections municipales
rappelons-nous en corse où l'ouverture
des écoles donc finalement on renvoie
toujours la balle aux élus locaux qui
finalement sont sur le terrain qui sont
là avec peu de moyens parce que quand
même étude les 36000 communes ya quand
même beaucoup des milliers de communes
n'ont pas de moyens le maire est souvent
seul face à l'adversité il ya la peur il
ya en guady citoyens qui est normal qui
est légitime et je suis très sincèrement
oui on a on attendait vraiment eu
discours des mesures au fort d'ailleurs
beaucoup de gens l'attendent et 1 ce
matin une nouvelle fois beaucoup de gens
ont parlé ça et là savoir ce qu'ils
allaient être qu'il y avait trop de
distance eu d'incident cette vision
finalement de la préco vite donc là on
nous a parlé de moi une nouvelle fois et
on nous attendait nous avons parlé quand
même des temps de dépistage on a
l'impression qu'on revient cinq mois en
arrière dans cette histoire là donc
c'est vrai que je suis très sincèrement
je suis très déçu parce qu'on attendait
aussi en moi aussi savoir un peu ce que
ce que le gouvernement allait nous
préparer et surtout de donner un point
très précis la situation du coc vide
voilà des points il en a annoncé un
retour des points presse du ministre de
la santé qui seront réguliers comme
pendant le confinement à priori
il ya aussi ces manifestations de noms
de ceux qui ne veulent plus justement de
mesures de restrictions et des patrons
de boîtes de nuit aussi qu'ils sont
complètement démunis face à cette crise
sanitaire est ce que c'était pas un
discours pour ne pas attiser justement
la colère de cela bien sûr alors sa
sélection intéressant parce que les
manifestations vous avez raison d'en
parler il ya aucune proportion de gens
une partie des gens aujourd'hui qui se
pose énormément de questions et je le
dis elles sont extrêmement légitime
ces questions là parce que cette crise
de corridas la montre et finalement
c'est l'affaiblissement absolu de la
part d'intimité là pour le public est
également également ça c'est extrêmement
important la veste imiter aussi de la
parole du corps médical
donc on se retrouve avec des gens
aujourd'hui quand vous n'avez pas de
ligne claire quand vous a menti sur les
masses comment on vous a menti sur toute
une série de choses qui étaient
essentielles à pouvoir tenir l'épidémie
ou du moins la juguler il faut bien
comprendre qu'au moment donné les
citoyens ils regardent comme nous et il
se rend compte que tout n'est pas clair
donc vous avez des mouvements spontanés
de gens qui ont marre qui sont agacés et
ça fait pas d'eux des complotistes ça
fait déjà un moment donné il faut avoir
une parole claire y la clarté un moment
donné à sow à la légitimité de la parole
publique et politique donc des mesures
qui seront pris sur ça donc demain la
manifestation effectivement au départ et
des jets jeu les jeunes vtc monde de la
nuit et qui aussi toute une population
aussi qu'ils commencent à à manifester
contre ces libertés l'instructif dix
estiment que les masques par exemple et
d'autres choses notamment sur la la
liberté de manifester kid est de moins
en moins pose un gros problème de
démocratie
voilà donc on est toujours pareil un
affaiblissement total de la légitimité
de la parole publique et de la parole
politique
merci beaucoup nicolas vidal d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rt france